okay I'm playing naka he wants to double
adopt me let's play chess
take a bishop no he forced me I resign
rematch okay that was really bad I was
slightly nervous let's play this line b3
b3 I'm winning a pawn back I think or
not your supposition is kind of solid
and win this pawn somehow defending
some theoretical reckoning
okay I resign I was rough okay I have
one goal not to get double adopted or
single adopted let's play what Carlson
played against him Carlson Nakamura from
some year in the past it's a nice line
94 is it about some g5 this is a better
opening crap play Bishop f4
I want to play east six at some point
maybe right now should see seven fancy
move g4 coming
he saw my threat ah h4 you can't see it
with Queen take with that double attack
look at arrows oh it didn't work though
let's play this move was h3 let's take a
free pawn mm queen see four straight
Queens because Queens are scary takes
and that he's being greedy trying to be
aggressive with my pieces after four
that doesn't do anything attacking from
behind threatening this
[Music]
I'm a bishop such a confusing position
but I have a pawn never mind
oh my gosh I just hung everything that
was so sad I was trying my best
I failed okay okay
b3 time
King prophylaxis Wow
very sneaky what is this I'm losing just
a rook losing everything oh so sad I'll
love them meet me oh yeah okay let's
play English try and confuse him playing
King's Indian
okay we'll play this line
I would like to meet in the future on h7
probably unlikely play workout 500 he
wants to fork let's play that in this
move what's going on here let me go for
all-out attack threatening this did that
do anything that didn't do anything I
was supposed to do something so I'm down
a rook but I have ideas when she stops
it's not working
how many G that's already five games
okay he still has a lot more two men
attack the Queen what is that move I'll
take that and let's play this
the encounter the Queen
and he's gonna win a pawn maybe hmm
[Music]
this is really unfortunate what can i
play this move no I can't
well I can play this move may be
threatening maiden one
oh he saw a queen I'm just losing is
there any hope
I want the rook to be trapped London
time okay this is what I like to see
this is a fun line play that he's
falling into traps oh oh wait is this a
trap it's kind of a trap
maybe the smooth okay this is very good
opening preparation he fell into one of
my classic London traps Bishop d6 is a
threat now let's not mess this up let's
just simplify and beat up material I've
never been knocked in my life and bullet
I also dropped a bishop he didn't take
it okay let's play ninety four ninety
two's a move okay let's just trade let's
keep training keep training keep trading
calm focus
hmm
three pong yes it's the lowest quality
bullet game
we've both played in a while oh my gosh
I just hung up to hang everything such a
little quality just wait I'm going for
mating attack trying to meet him for the
king oh my gosh
no how am I losing this game no I was
such a bad game but such a good game to
like was crushing in the opening I need
to win more positions
and the aggressive age for ideas
hey let's move let's play this first g5
ideas double exclam let's play that's h3
is attached and take that let's move
attack from all angles let's play this
what's going on here
there's still some camp
that's really unfortunate you just it's
really unfortunate to play this move
okay maybe oh no that's getting crushed
don't the only hope here is to set up my
likes this stalemate trap
you just made someone okay I'm I'm down
eight to zero oh my gosh what am i doing
there's no focus okay let's come back I
have Center I'm down a piece but I have
Center take those three based on the way
we've both been playing there's hope in
this position can I take the half fun I
could take the let's move the Queen back
those Queens our target now c4 rook here
Bishop here
okay going all out against f7 queen of
six check the move I don't want to be
adopted he's thinking wait where's my
win h4 I guess to break down the
barricade work g3 ideas
I take I can't take let's play play that
years of Queen takes h5 ah he found
tactics oh okay I'm trying
let's not hang a piece this time d4 okay
this is a fine opening I think h5h 4x5
to knock at the bishop trapped
and he gave away his dark squared bishop
which means my dark squared bishop my
flourish creating the battery here I'd
use a b5 it's difficult though I'm just
gonna wait around for a little bit
mmm just doing things he's doing more
things which I do so confused I want to
play b5 he's gonna get a square let's
play this move hide the bishop
my queen trapped house my queen trapped
oh I have this move
still trying to meet my both bishops are
alive I'll open the file
oh dear play this move jack ooh
I took a thing oh but you took a thing
take that thing that was an unfortunate
finish okay London some kind of berry
attack
g4s Queen h2
can I take on d6 and then this move
you
what's going on here okay let's play
this
I'm opening files but I'm losing pawns
let's take that tack the bishop still
want to open files stop attacking me
turning mate
I was a weird move oh he's gonna make me
I bet this move I was maybe winning at
some points there that kind of match was
a long time okay let's put the pitch for
again I mean I like this variation let's
put the bishop here someone else I have
five
yeah he's attacking let's just take
pawns and not get meted oh no he set up
a tricky trap but I can take this can
take that and then work be seven if he
takes let's go after the pawn let's move
I want to make a pass pawn
he wants to meet me what to do how am I
so alive I'm still alive what do I do
I'm just losing here play that that's 12
zero but I have hope
okay and plainly Carlsen line again
Bishop g4 Civ move I think so we're
going into some other variation hmm take
there I think we take c7 what's going on
I want to trap the rook on f8 go Eric
Thanks oh thanks for the thousand bits
I'm down some games those Knights kind
of stuck okay some hope
now his night is free what's the pawn
count I'm only down one pawn it could be
worse
bring the King to f3 I need to take the
b-pawn never mind let's defend the C
pawn take that and routine one coming
time is actually okay this game I want
to play c4 explosive and maybe even c5
and maybe a three Oh tricky tricky very
tricky let's play this move
what's the King pawn ending am I losing
mm-hmm I'm losing stalemate me please
okay he's playing this like dubious
opening but it's kind of working
we're getting the same position a game
after game let's put the bishop here
maybe this time I'll rook lift okay so
we have a new type of position king d3
what's king d3 let's play c5 on the
center maybe Brooke h5 next hit the
Queen and then Castle queenside
deafening d7 I'm liking my position oh I
hung a rock no but I have red smooth
Jack that's so sad what do I do
there's wow that's more bits sympathy
bits okay I'm gonna play this line again
I'm so tricky okay this is a solid
position I'll hold my own
he's playing f6 the center is kind of
opened this air and I'll take and then
play that makes you six ideas oh maybe
I'm doing okay c4 take and take can take
here maybe it'll lose b7 or B - that's a
strong looking move it's a very annoying
looking move 92 spy check
I mean I'm just lost here right nothing
I have nothing
oh no I'm not getting double okay no
five more games I'll try them in at
least one let's check on pass on some
normal-looking position okay let's play
play let's keep the bishop here just
down the pawn and down on time and we'll
get one of these work endings again I
want to get active rooks yeah this is
what I need active rooks active rooks
always play off 6 mg v g5 oh no I'm
getting meted no I should play King f7
okay so c6 let's play c4 this time we
have some position there should be 5
yeah we can trade I just want to get
like some simple position we're not down
material and not down too much time and
maybe have some attack I can take that
no let's come back five is interesting
he wants to beat me again
can take this he's over pushing a little
bit I'm ninety five pawns can't move
backwards can play this move and then
check on them c-4 explosive and maybe f3
always play off three hmm this is
getting spicy oh he wants to fork me but
I have this move and then ok let's trade
Lucky seven coming
he wants to flag me too
to take this pawn
there's no mate
am i meeting him I might be meeting him
how does he avoid mates rookie Jay
coming
No I thought I was meeting him but he
escaped somehow oh I'm so sad his
happiness just causes my sentence all
right let's play this move I'm 95 I miss
me so much tilt this move nice night
let's play this move battery time mm-hmm
he wants to win upon how do I not lose
upon here okay I'll play that slight
concession maybe this move yeah there's
a tricky line right here and then he
says I'm not the exchange still very
tricky though his pawns force
so scary I have to play g5 some points
and g4 through this whoa gifting sobs
okay I want to break through oh no I
didn't quite work no stop it stop okay
he's not going to Dhabi also things Duke
for something something it's like a for
prophylaxis for coming
d5 maybe okay trying to make things
spicy plate oh I didn't mean to castle
but I have to live with my decisions and
my mouse lips
okay I'm going in entering his crib I
want to take on b5 does that do anything
no that does anything let's retreat
first I want to take on b5 still and
then play a six in the future he keeps
doing things now maybe takes a six
coming oh wait let's not get mated I can
play maybe chief he's doing things again
g3 I guess let's take what pong did I
take no play this move I guess how am I
not meeting him I have so many pieces
like a focusing I'm like kingside what's
that I'm just gonna try and stay focused
losing all the pawns
wait there's a lot riding on this game
there's double adoption riding on this
game
32 maybe 32 in c4 and just oh wait am I
getting mated again have this move at
least oh my gosh she's got fort I have
this move so I'm getting some counter
play this is so sad though because I
might be getting needed I'm also getting
counter play okay thanks for the bits
soggy
good games was rough I mean that's more
of a quadruple adoption he adopted me
maybe like a couple years ago he really
sucked the rating points out of me but
I'm still above 2500 and I think maybe
kind of sort of yeah I'm still I'm
twenty five over one I was playing
Nakamura for those of you who don't know
yeah how's ruff
maybe that will go on YouTube for the
YouTube audience you can press us in the
comments and pay respects yeah I've
never been knocking more in bullets and
being Carlsen bullet twice oh thanks for
all the apps I feel so respected what's
my score II owe my score
well my score is now zero to 20 against
year of the rabbit against other I guess
NACA's are their account I think it's
like 42 to zero I tried
I have kombucha follow your guts
cheer up yeah I appreciate the sympathy
bets and the sympathy subs for ranks
thanks for subbing was his name and Duke
man walk thanks for gifting subs to
Logan rhythm GM auntie was Alby chess a
coin me oh and gauzy Olga key welcome
everyone to being a sub ya what to do
next time oh he's challenging me again
okay I'll play them again this time will
be different
this time I'll play like now I'm warmed
up at least play for a year so there's a
Carlson game which is very similar to
this line I'm gonna keep time study and
Center study as well this move at the
pawn each floor
maybe H five and nine each - I know
that's three this night is very annoying
on before so I'll move the Knight to c3
my pawn was kind of stuck my rook is
stuck
it's my rook stuck it's okay look sorry
- meaningful in this position put the
bishop
I put the night there it's other knights
coming in okay how do I sack just want
to sack and open up the King no dear
can I take this I think I can take and
then this check okay so down on time
know what's going on here it's Queens a
bit stuck
wait now I'm a bit stuck no I'm so close
that's so far okay Lacey five this time
[Music]
positional chess tactics men game
wait am i sort of coming back what's
going on here
how does he win
oh that's how he wins no steal matrix I
tried it was actually a close finish
yeah let's play with Knights Knights can
be tricky and bullet he's committed to
f6
play let's move oh this is slightly
uncomfortable
slightly really uncomfortable play this
move it takes maybe g3
what do I do here I don't know what to
do I can cry I got three coming I'm
defending really trying to defend I'm
getting me then I okay let's play
reverse London can't be a bad opening
no no okay so you got the triple adopt
me please don't please don't
again I like the opening the bishop here
put the rook in
okay I'm gonna go for some meaning
attack despite the fact that there's no
Queens okay I have a mating attack I
think my winning this I might be winning
I'm attacking the knight and threatening
mate and if he takes then I I mean work
g5 the threat to King f8 okay chase I
won a game I be Nakamura okay first win
in my life at least one bullet it's not
a time to adopt him back let's play this
okay all I need is one game one win to
have confidence it's all about
confidence also is he winning material
might be winning material oh but I have
a trick although he has tricks hmm he's
winning both my rooks what how's this
happening what's going on okay
what okay that was slightly unfortunate
okay okay at least I want a game let's
play a different system let's play h4
and just go for a quick attack but the
bishop on g5 play this move
hey it's up sting it's a donation for
the win thanks for donating $10 who
donated are Beasley thanks for donating
okay I kind of got two wins and that's
bits 500 debts for taking down naka
minute ago gggg yo e 6 OE z 6 good good
move or a bad move ok let's play king f1
and rook e1
ok well put the pawn here Pass pawn in
the middle game it's like Moses crossing
the Dead Sea there's a path for London
style take on g6 mmm take back
sadly I'm not getting much here
I'm trying to get something though oh no
no okay
this line again f4 what's f4 oh that
would be bad let's take and I'll go for
g5 BAM what free pawn he's gonna get
some pressure 19 for coming
this isn't so bad I want to play f5 I
actually like my position down the
exchange but I have pawns
I think's for something whoever that was
let's play this move I'll ignore the
pawns for now I take with take with rook
probably open the G file like a G let's
play Queenie here rook g3 ideas mmm
that's annoying let's play this move
hitting the Jeep on now f4 ooh
f4 such a nice move unleashing the
bishop and unleashing arrows and
obstructing the Queen oh he found a
counter move can take this may be
threatening rip g2 g2
am i meeting how am I not meeting here
Jack Brooks defended no
I have to self steal me myself no he
comes by checking me I'm singing about
2500 though let's move Knights versus
bishops I'll post square of6 is strong
let's play this move in 95 ah forgot
about that
let's play nicely 5 anyway Queen e2 I
guess maybe take it let's play that move
I can play or exceed 1 c6 is backwards
b3 positional play h3 prophylaxis rook
c5 positional if you take the bishop and
then triple up on the C file ok we'll go
into this put the knight back somewhere
a more useful play this move h4 spawn
sack o rook sac what
let's take here I have a knight though
I'm sorry sometimes tricky mmm except
when they're not play this move enough
for outpost I look up to threatening g4
he stopped it
okay I wanna win the H pawn he wants to
activate the king o play this move this
move I guess not sure what's going on
here I think I'm losing kind of oh my
knight is awkward I'm trying made in one
well he see it
please don't see it I saw it I need
tricks with my night I tried by h5
okay I guess I should take
well Queen takes it's not expecting that
it is Knights versus bishops this time I
have their bishops let's move the King
and control the file keep the bishops
maybe you're up G eights cath open file
I could double up let's put the rook
here first and c5 that's a move ooh
takes takes interest in I'm in the pond
oh I lose a bishop no I don't it's
complicated this is very complicated
take that
King c7 let's push some a pawn and
attack the e3 pawn III is backwards I'll
push the pawn attack double attack can
take this
everything's pins kind of I should have
taken on c4 let's go back and defend we
can take this and check f6 BAM okay
defend some more mmm what is this
position
no he made it me oh I was feeling good
that game to d5
take care I can get away with that
tactics
let's take here
I'll have c4 in the end so explosive
play this d6 important move cannot the
exchange his tricks hmm why is this so
confusing so confused
I only work out six
let's move Chuck I just want to meet
somehow how do I meet tried he made a
new two or three
stupid
yes still mates sorry green screen hey
thanks for the raid King Bishop I
survived it was a draw yes let's play
this and being slightly passive I should
really try and be passive-aggressive the
night here whew d5 moon c5 check can win
back the pond to take with the bishop in
the end
slightly uncomfortable - I do like this
move this move and my structure isn't so
preferable play this move
now that doesn't work okay I need to set
up another stalemate trap I okay let's
do this oh no oh so sad
still me no okay
it's taken h4 new position slightly
dubious maybe I have a pawn in each six
I would like to justify it
what do I do here let's play that move
and let's move try and come in from
behind maybe a four a five ideas hmm
what do I do
it's such a difficult situation at least
maybe I'm winning the pawn or maybe not
he keeps finding these resources please
play rock a6 attack from behind
Jack we wants to me me where is this
coming from
Chuck is hoping for some stone eights
ting clay work accidental French excuse
my French play this move this work maybe
it works and this move okay this is
playable at least play this yeah let's
take this control the d4 square very
positional and then go in for the kill
I could take twice okay this is a very
good position this is a very very good
position
oh he's defending mate with the Queen
let's take with the with the knight
attack
how's he defending these positions no my
position was so good and now it's so bad
but let's push up on still have hope
English double attack not sure if I
should take that probably not I'll put
the Queen on c5 nice square let's take
that
oh no he's gonna take and do stuff but I
have this move it's still interesting
I'm still definitely interesting does
this work no it doesn't or does it
where's my mate
oh that's a trick
I tried half for again this isn't
supposed to be a good position for white
he's playing it free foam let's go in
for the kill
see trapping my queen why does this
always happen to me
okay I can get stuff for us maybe
this back
he just wants to make me okay this is a
tactic
not working okay
it's 34 0.5 to 1.5
that's something right not h3 Knight g5
ooh I have f4 I guess maybe for rooks
III comment
play this move take that very strange
position I'm down the exchange but maybe
there's some comp rook c5 moving the
bishop I have to play aggressively oh
there's no tactics it's unfortunate but
my bishops are in playing is rooks are
out of play can play this move
threatening meet movie castles play this
move why am I always so low on time
I tried something there okay
again I'm liking the position very much
liking the position play this move could
take that let's take that outside passer
and push the queenside majority and some
ideas of c-4 hmm it's interesting move
so ops are color bishops let's play this
F to pass pawns and I breakthrough I
should defend from the distance it's
crazy
oh I was queen I was up a full queen
hang in there Eric these games are
really fun to watch yeah I'm hanging I'm
hanging more pieces I'm hanging in there
but thanks for the moral support let's
develop a night let's do this in 95
- thanks for that let's see for
explosive I could take that I'll take
here looks very wrong but I want to win
b5 ok I'll play a 3 here he's being
crazy let's play this move let's be
crazier Queen C for coming I could take
that who can do this let's take up on
controlling d3 with my knight this is
unpleasant it was very unpleasant let's
take that no he's doing things again no
ok
oh no kinks are my queenside pawn
structure could use some help maybe
no I saw this forked and see the other
Fork
oh no did I just hang everything oh this
I have nothing here so sad
ok one last trick Queen a3 and rookie 7
this is not working okay how do I deal
with this line play Bishop g4 me 7
leave some tension thanks for the bits
road you're a bona something like a
castle and check and then maybe this
move
a bit more comfortable than usual not so
high before attacking h4 yeah let's go
pawn grabbing cuz I've to choose hanging
now ooh
forgot about that move let's go back I
might just be getting mated but maybe
there'll be some miracle mm-hmm maybe
not what to do
yes okay so we have another one of these
lines
this one not the happiest square for the
night
what did you kingi to delayed bon cloud
attention attention is very difficult to
deal with play g3 and hang a rook I have
active King the very least
this is difficult
I keep getting like punched in the face
I want him to Castle kingside is just so
I can have one great gift let's play b6
what does this move takes takes okay
let's try this sacking a queen but then
the knight is stuck on b7 but my bishop
is stuck where's my bishop go my bishop
has no squares
this is h2 to misplace lorac his night
is still stuck that's controlling d8
okay I'm gonna go and try the rosin trap
which involves putting my look somewhere
my pond somewhere
aha what didn't work okay
play this one Bishop e2
okay I can't complain with this really
can't complain with this pay for
Wow so greedy play this move point out
for maybe f4
hmm could take on g6 maybe let's play
this first and see three solid
doesn't even take it okay that's fine
what's going on here
oh no no I tried I really tried I need a
break can I take a break if I'm already
broken
I was really rough was naka
even gaining points for beating me not
sure yeah he was a good sports even if
he like quadruple adopted me Gigi yo
actually Gigi's you know that was a lot
of chess I don't know how prepared I was
for that
you